good morning everyone welcome back
thanks for your determination for
sticking with us
thanks for your patience um we very much
appreciate it
our first speaker today is steve hodges
we're going to jump right in steve is
going to be talking to us about
addressing accessibility with physical
computing
steve mike's yours thanks roy
uh hello everyone i'm super excited to
uh to be here
uh today and uh have this opportunity to
present some uh some ideas
uh to you so uh as roy said i'm steve
hodges
i'm in i work for microsoft research i'm
in cambridge in the uk
so uh it's the uh it's the evening here
for me
i know we've got people from all around
the world and
i'm actually going to start with an
apology so the title of my talk
changed actually overnight based on uh
on some of the great discussions we had
yesterday
and i mean obviously not just the title
but the content of my talk changed quite
a bit
so uh so the sides are coming in hot and
uh
in particular i i've done my best in
terms of uh you know tagging the images
and
and so on and so forth with the copy of
the deck that you have access to
but please accept my apologies for that
not being quite as polished
as i would have liked
so by way of uh introduction i was going
to start actually with um
with a disclaimer so i
am a hardware researcher i'm not a
computer science
education expert and i'm not an
accessibility
expert so please bear that in mind and
and in case i kind of allude to any
expertise in those areas
your job is to help keep me honest
but as a harder researcher my day job
really is to
imagine design build and evaluate
different types of interactive device so
this slide here shows examples of things
i've worked on new types of input device
environmental sensors uh new types of
display
for example but you might notice that
some of the things in this slide aren't
really
devices and i also work on tools and
systems that help other people
create electronic devices and i'm going
to spend quite a bit of time today
talking about one example of this
and that's a system called net gadgeteer
so donaire gadgeteer is a physical
computing toolkit if you will
it for those of you not familiar with
the term physical computing
i i put a definition here on the slide
uh combining software and hardware to
build
interactive practical physical systems
that sense and respond to the real world
so physical computing of course is
therefore used to describe
many of those in interactive devices i
put
in the previous slide
and often these interactive physical
systems support communications
so that means that devices can talk with
other devices and so broadly physical
computing also
relates to the uh to the iot
so dotnet gadgeteer was designed to
enable the
quick construction programming and
evaluation of
physical computing devices we actually
um created.net gadgeteer in the first
instance as a tool
to accelerate our own device research we
wanted to be able to build stuff
more quickly so we could try more things
out more quickly
[Music]
and gadgety consists of a set of
hardware modules
each of them and has some kind of
functionality so in the picture here
some example modules
so there's a joystick here um there's a
light sensor here there's a
and some leds here and these modules all
plug
into a processor board and the processor
board is programmed
so that it consumes some of these sensor
inputs and maybe controls the output
like
like the display
so when we created a gadget here we aim
to do two things
which are often difficult to do
simultaneously we wanted a very low
threshold
so that simple gadgets could be made
really quickly matter of minutes
and we also wanted a high ceiling so
that you could build quite sophisticated
devices with it to support our research
sophisticated both in terms of the
hardware they supported and in terms of
the software
functionality
so we kind of thought of gadgeteer in
terms of pillars and
and so the first two pillars relate to
hardware and software as
i just described but we were also
conscious of this third pillar on the
right
the notion of design and the form factor
of devices we wanted a system that you
could use to make quite compact devices
and was compatible with
technologies like 3d printing which back
then was still emerging
and to give you an example you know
here's an example of something we built
an alarm clock in the middle at the top
there you can see
the modules it's made from there's a
main processor board in the middle
and there's two little oled displays on
either side and various other
sensors and controls around the outside
at the top right you can see how these
modules all fit together
and down in the bottom right everything
is a photo of everything actually
inside a 3d printed enclosure
so so that's physical computing
what what does that got to do with
accessibility and computer science
education well as we were developing
uh dot-net gadgeteer we started showing
people uh we demoed our devices to
people
and um it was a bit frustrating actually
because we were trying to show people
these amazing devices we built and and
time and again they were more interested
in the platform we'd use to build
the devices rather than the things
themselves and and some of the people
that
saw our devices and our platform were
teachers
and to put this in context this was
before the big
k-12 computer science education
revolution
that was kick-started by things like the
royal society report and
you know obama administration computer
science for all initiatives
so this stuff hadn't happened at that
time
around the world mostly for the most
part k-12 students
did not have computer science in their
curriculum they were not really learning
about uh programming or computational
thinking
of course we taught all our students we
taught them ict that was we were
teaching how to use existing computer
systems
we just we're not teaching them how to
create the computing systems of the
future
so one of the um many
uh people who were beginning to wake up
to this concern
um and who also saw.net gadgeteer saw
our prototypes was a lady called
sue sentence and we teamed up with sue
and ran a number of pilot studies in um
in the uk and the us with dot net
gadgety in high schools
so in the uk i think we had 16 schools
and we worked with
the 11 to 17 age group and we have a
slightly
older cohort of children in suburban
public schools in the u.s in three
suburban public high schools
and i won't go into the details of the
work there are some publications which
go into a lot more detail about exactly
what we did and what we found
but in a nutshell we uncovered
many benefits to physical computing
so just to kind of sketch over over
these here of course there are technical
skills
that we were able to give the students
we were teaching them
programming we were teaching them
high-level computer science
concepts we were teaching about graphics
and user interface and user interaction
we also gave them a more holistic view
from a technical perspective so
i think a lot of them ahead of time
thought computing was all about
programming
but through physical computing we showed
them there was much more to it than that
there are these other elements and and
they're you know it's really a
multidisciplinary
field when you consider it more broadly
but we also noticed a large number of
soft skills
being developed so first of all was
creativity the students naturally
related
to the technology and the task and it
just gave them so many ideas
and the ideas weren't again just about
programming they were
all aspects of computer systems so it
created a very collaborative inclusive
environment especially when students
were working in groups we would find
everyone was included and everyone
although everyone was exposed to the
whole process people found different
areas they found their niche and they
found the thing that
that they could contribute
physical computing promotes a different
way of thinking about solving problems
because
a couple of reasons i think first of all
there are
many different ways to solve a given
problem and so
that gives you a different perspective
it's not like you have to learn the one
way to do it correctly
and also right by its very nature you
get very physical very quickly and so it
becomes a very
iterative process and again that's a
different way of problem solving
and of course the tangible tactile
nature of
the the physical devices the students
find it very engaging
and it helps them make connections
and also uh we found that there was a
lot of
opportunity for connections across the
curriculum so you might
use your physical computing skills to
build a device but then you might deploy
the device
in the environment and use it to measure
something and use those measurements to
inform what you're learning in biology
or what you're learning in
in geography
and i think the the final point i put
that which in some ways i think is the
most important was motivation
our students bear in mind in the uk you
know it was not this was not part of the
curriculum you couldn't choose to
do computer science and then get a
meaningful qualification out of it at
the time
so this was an extracurricular activity
the kids were doing this
because they wanted to after school and
we found we had tremendous engagement
in particular we we got a very good
balance at gender balance we had as many
uh girls wanting to do this as boys and
i think in part it was because the
students were focused on on the end
artifact
right so they had a goal in mind and
kind of almost by subterfuge we taught
them computer science along the way
but they certainly didn't see it as
being taught computer science they saw
it as
as learning to build the thing they
wanted to build
so i've got some photos here of things
that students made just to give you an
idea
up in the top left here is a an alarm
system
so we had this student uh joe and she
had this idea
to build an alarm for an important piece
of artwork maybe like a vars
and so the idea is you would place the
vars on top of this plinth and there's a
little push button there and so that
would sort of activate
you know on the alarm because the button
would get depressed
and then if anyone took the bars the
button would uh ping open
and that would trigger the system lights
would flash an alarm would sound and
there's a camera this black circle here
is actually a camera lens
it would take a photo of the culprit
this is a space invaders game with a
little joystick that moves the
spacecraft around
and there's a fire button you can use to
shoot missiles
uh up here is a an etcher sketch the
classic etcher sketch
kind of game with two rotary knobs to
control
the line that you draw on the screen
this in the bottom left is a
it's a reaction that game so colored
lights would
would light up suddenly at the bottom
and you had to press the corresponding
button very quickly
in order to score points and in the
bottom right we've got a camera
so you can see that there's quite a lot
of creativity here people are building
very different things
there's quite a level of sophistication
in these devices right they're not just
blinking an led
and and we even achieved i think our
third aim with gadgeteer
which was to have people thinking about
the former devices and we've got some
sort of craft
more craft like um devices on the left
and on the right we've got some more
sophisticated devices this has been
laser cut the enclosure for the camera
and this enclosure was actually vacuum
formed
so hopefully now you can see how
physical computing can make computer
science
education more accessible and computer
science more broadly
but can we make physical computing
itself more accessible
well there's already a big range of
options in terms of physical computing
this table here is taken from a paper
which was published at the beginning of
the year i i put the citation
earlier in an earlier slide and the
photos on the right
give you some idea of the products in
this space
in the left we we've actually
categorized uh
these products very broadly and these
groups are starting at the top we've got
electronic kits
and then we have you know more
self-contained uh programmable devices
or sometimes these are a kits
modular kits i guess and then underneath
that we've got different types of board
level solutions
so as we move down through these
different categories there is increasing
flexibility
so very very broadly the products at the
top tend to be more constrained
in the range of things you can do so in
the case of a turtle
of course you can map out any path you
want
but fundamentally you're limited to
mapping out paths
and as you move down the list you find
that you get
more flexibility so towards the bottom
you've got these general purpose
single board computers like the
raspberry pi i can kind of do anything
and while the products at the top are
pretty easy to use
as you go down what typically happens is
things take a little bit they're a
little bit more complicated so
if any of you have used raspberry pi for
example from scratch you know you've
gone out of the box and set it up
you might have found it was a bit
involved just to get going
and as i mentioned before with gadgets
here we wanted to get the best of
best sorry of both worlds we wanted this
very low threshold to get going but
quite a high ceiling
and i think our school pilots showed
we actually did a pretty good job i've
got a couple of quotes here on on the
slide and and both of them allude to
the you know the open-ended nature of
dotnet gadgeteer so
one student said well you can be
creative and make anything really you
weren't limited in what you could do you
could take an idea anyway
and someone else another student
commented on the fact that once they
built something they could iterate on it
they could always add
more functionality in part this was
enabled because we actually had over 100
different hardware modules
that you could use with a gadgetear
system from eight different
manufacturers
but there was a drawback from all this
and i've got a couple of other quotes
here which illustrate this
so one of our teachers uh you know one
pilot commented that
they had to deal with a problem because
the version of software they had
wasn't quite compatible with the set of
modules they had and it wasn't quite
clear it caused them some confusion
and another comment that i picked up
from online
is quite correct was that the way that
we designed gadgeteer
not all of the processor boards were
compatible with all of the module boards
and that caused some confusion as well
as you can imagine how i mean we
documented it of course but if you're a
busy teacher you might not have had time
to read all the documentation
so when the opportunity to work with the
bbc
on the micro bit came along
we were super excited we wanted to go
further in terms of
that that low threshold we wanted to do
something that gave immediate results
something that always works in the
classroom
where you didn't have to worry about
what software to install where students
could never get distracted because they
were
waiting uh for some you know software
installation to finish
so we created a web-based experience
that needs no software installation you
just
run it in the web browser and from a
hardware perspective we made this
very simple small device it's got a
display built into it basic sensing
built into it so you don't have to
attach anything
to get going now
of course we didn't want to compromise
on that high ceiling either
but with microbit we took a slightly
different approach we've got this edge
connector
on the side of the device and it's
possible using the edge connect is
possible to extend the hardware you can
use crocodile clips
to connect to these little holes here
and and doing that you can connect
simple bits of hardware like headphones
or an extra button or any edit
sorry an led but there's also an
ecosystem of accessories you can buy
that that the whole device
plugs into so you can buy little robots
and you plug your micro bit into the
robot and then
the micro bit controls the robot
and from a software perspective we have
this notion of packages
that can be added in the web browser so
that depending on what hardware you want
to use
you can make sure that the programming
environment supports it
another aim for microbit of course was
low cost
and the component cost is actually less
than ten dollars which means these
devices retail for about fifteen dollars
and and we've now made five million
micro bits
which we estimate to have been used in a
meaningful way
to learn computer science concepts by 25
million children
so so in a sense we've achieved our goal
right
physical computing is much more
accessible than it was before
one percent of the children on the
planet have used this device
but of course we all know that
accessibility is multifaceted
and and one issue with microbit perhaps
is is that the composability that we had
with.net gadgeteer
is limited
so we've been working on a new system in
msr
which we call jack dac
in many ways jack dac is a standard for
physical computing
it's a bit like usb but for low-cost
microcontrollers
so somewhat like dot-net gadgets here
jack dac is a modular system
so you build a new hardware device by
plugging together different modules
everything uses the same type of cable
and the cables provide
power as well as connectivity
unlike most existing physical computing
systems
each device presents a common interface
electronically
so interoperability is is built in
it doesn't matter what kind of
accelerometer you have or where you plug
it in
it's much like plugging a usb webcam
into your pc it should just work
and we've managed to do this hopefully
without increasing cost
you know key factor as i mentioned
before in keeping the technology
accessible
so uh jacktack is is still a work in
progress
we we have some early prototypes and
we're hoping to have
more prototypes in the first half of
next year
and one of the things we'd really like
to do is get your thoughts and your
feedback
on this system on what you might find it
useful for
and also perhaps you know new modules
that we might be able to build
specifically to address particular
accessibility needs
so i put some some uh my first thoughts
as it were on the slide here
these are very probably very obvious
examples but if you're working with
micro bit perhaps you could plug in a
larger display or larger buttons
perhaps a different type of feedback
haptic feedback
for example or just different modalities
but but more than
these simple examples perhaps we can
unlock different experiences for
physical
computing like the physical programming
experience that cecily and others worked
on
with that other the other microsoft
research project code jumper
so i hope that's given you um an idea of
our aspirations to make physical
computing
more accessible and the final part of my
talk
i wanted to come up another level in a
sense
and think about accessibility much more
generally
so let me return for a moment to the
definition of
physical computing we've got
combining software and hardware to build
an interactive physical system
that senses and responds to the real
world
now if you think about it every time we
use digital technology we rely on some
kind of physical computing
to bridge between our physical world and
the virtual world of the computer
the the keyboard and the mouse and the
lcd monitor
that i'm using right now are are
examples of this
and i could say the standard forms of
interaction for most of us
but by using physical computing we can
build alternatives to these we could
debate different types of tangible
interfaces
we can think about sensors that maybe
automatically detect the context of the
user
so maybe um i've got
a sensor on my door to my office so that
when someone opens the door to my office
i automatically go on mute
in case i'm just about to be interrupted
and we could also think about
experiences which are targeted
at very specific user groups so these
could be completely
new devices not just things like
new versions as it were of the mouse and
the keyboard these could be completely
new
uh maybe standalone devices are not
related to
interaction with with a regular computer
so i wanted to give you one example of
this
this is a smart walking stick and
uh this idea actually came from uh
one of the schools who worked in our
took part in our gadgeteer
pilots that i mentioned before we
actually ran a competition amongst these
schools
and ask them to come up with ideas of
what they'd like to build
with gadgeteer and so this is this was
actually one of the winning entries
uh these students said well they wanted
to make a smart walking cane
so it was gonna have a camera on it and
it'll push button so that if you were
using the cane you don't have to worry
about fiddling with the camera you could
take photos as you're out and about you
could easily take photos
but more than that it's also got motion
sensors in it so it's got an
accelerometer and a gyro
and it would automatically detect
unusual motion so
if the user dropped the stick or fell
over perhaps a stick fell
it could detect that and you know could
use that to take a photo as well
it also has a um sorry it has a
uh cellular radio so it could send
messages
in the event of one of these incidents
and it has
gps so if it needed to it could it could
alert someone as to the location
where this incident had happened
so our vision for physical computing
goes beyond
creating the engagement with technology
and
creating an engagement around computer
science education
we see physical computing not just as a
tool for education
but a tool for makers and ultimately for
everyone
a vehicle for people to think creatively
about technology
and to build their own interactive
devices
we think it's super important uh because
it means
in a world where increasingly we're all
becoming technology consumers
actually we can redress that balance and
we could we all have the potential
becoming
technology creators
we think it physical computing
can empower organizations and
communities and individuals
to build solutions to address specific
needs
it's not just doing it in order to learn
and to understand it's a
it's it's a it's an end in itself for
many people and we think this
ultimately is what's going to empower
everyone to get the very best from what
technology has to offer
thank you thank you steve
um super interesting stuff it's really
great to see how the uk has really
embraced
the sort of educational arc of computer
science education
for k through 12 and beyond uh and it's
and it's
super interesting to see how something
like gadgeteer and jackdack could plug
into that
unintended not intended um we do have a
few questions and we have five minutes
so i'm going to encourage you to answer
each of these questions fairly quickly
about a minute or so for each one
uh the first one is you've talked about
empowering people to build prototype
devices to suit their particular needs
do you have any thoughts about scaling
up how would you go about making more
copies or making a product for others to
use
okay super interesting so i try and do
this uh
this is a really interesting question i
thought it might come up because it came
up yesterday on our discussions in my
workshop
i'll try and be brief so so we think of
prototyping right
and and it's interesting to drill down
on what that means because prototype is
really just to start some people
sometimes think well i've got a
prototype i could just make copies of it
right like photocopying
and you know with documents we can make
copies easily with with software we can
make copies easily but with hardware
it's actually really hard
so prototype if you think about it you
might have one of them or maybe you have
a few
and if you've got it right it will kind
of work like you imagine then it looks
like
roughly like how you imagine um
but uh but sometimes that next step of
going to a product that might actually
be overkill
uh you know because a product you might
making tens or hundred thousands of a
year it you know might be
super cost optimized there's a lot of
complexity in doing that
and making this transition from
prototype is actually remarkably
treacherous
you know i put some some publications
here which talk about why this is but
you you know
i'm sure we've all heard of kickstarters
that failed where there was a prototype
that had all the promise
but turning it to product turned
actually really hard and
and so we are um we have a separate
maybe we should you know if people are
particularly interested we could take
this offline but we are developing
uh tools and techniques to cross this
treacherous chasm as it were
but we also think it's useful to
introduce a new term which we call
isotype so if you think about it a
prototype
technically means the first one of
that's what proto means only one of it
really exists the moment you have
multiple copies of it they're not all
prototypes anymore
and so we think of them as isotypes
they're equivalent copies
but they might not be fully fledged
products yet and um
and we think this process of isotyping
is actually ripe
for the research community uh because it
it requires it first of all it gives you
a new perspective i think and it
requires new tools
and ultimately we think that we can
create a solution
that helps people do this scaling which
might which might fulfill the needs of a
particular
community or individual because they
only need 10 or 100
particular pieces or it might also just
act as the springboard to test out an
idea better it might help researchers
really evaluate an idea at a bit more
scale before they then make that next
step
okay sorry i must stop there great um
i think we have time for just one more
question um for everyone listening
and asking questions your questions will
be shared with the speakers so if
they're not able to answer them
live during the talks they will be uh
encouraged to answer them offline
um this last question i'm just going to
read sort of the second half of it where
the i think the meatiest part of the
question is it's
uh from someone who works at a micro
micro school for students with learning
disabilities
and uh the question is are there
training supports around
physical computing that could help us
learn while we are doing
and or any people organizations out
there that are interested in partnering
with a micro school
that functions as a learning lab do you
come across anything like that
um so the broad answer is absolutely yes
i'm not familiar with micro schools
and so i you know i don't know which of
the many
i guess support you know mechanisms are
out out there would be
most uh suitable for you perhaps the
easiest thing for me to do
is try and find that question in the in
the chat or whatever and and post some
links
but there are there's a big variety of
physical computing
solutions out there you know i put some
of them on that slide but for anyone
for most of them you'll find lots of
resources online
and so these are things like teaching
materials so certainly microbit which is
one that's close to our hearts
in microsoft and the make code
programming environment that goes with
it there's a huge amount
of resources and tutorials and guides as
well as
you know stuff you can buy to go with it
troubleshooting guides
arduino is very similar there's a lot of
stuff on raspberry pi
great thank you very much steve uh
very much appreciate uh the talk uh
the rapid fire responses that uh you
gave us for these questions
um it's very exciting stuff um and
we look forward to seeing what happens
to jack duck and gadgeteer in the future
thank you thanks